hold on yeah yeah she said don't ever
come to my house again can you imagine
that what I say to your to his mother
because of
he's trying
are you kidding me
with the kids in my house my
mother-in-law
said that she would stay at the house
and she was gonna stay overnight just to
make sure everything was okay and the
kids were okay and everything was good
and then Marina called me and said that
he's kicking us out and the driver is
gone
so I think that the girl or somebody's
coming over here
yeah
yeah
and then my mother-in-law said she saw
the driver pull in because she was
parked outside of the house and there
was a girl in the back of our car
of course I'm freaking out I'm I am
freaking out okay that's that's it
that's it I'm calling the lawyer I'm
that's it
I'm feeling I'm being cheated on there's
a woman being snuck into my house
amongst my kids amongst my belongings
just to be in my home with my husband
doing God knows what God knows where
what
no no no no no no no no no no your mom
you're you're trying to bring that girl
to my house with my kids in there
so what
yeah really
because I'm gonna have somebody come see
and make sure that there's that [ __ ] is
not in my house
do you understand me
you bring that girl anywhere near my
kids there's gonna be a huge problem
[Music]
Marina this is crazy I don't know what
to do how do I
I don't know how to handle this
monkey are you in here
what's going on
the girls in my house I believe with the
and my kids are sleeping and I don't
know what to do you need to take control
of the situation he's not controlling
the situation
blocking me and my kids already wanted
the nanny inside the house what
what Marina is he crazy
is he crazy can Marina go there you need
to make sure you can get in the house
what if he changed the locks you need to
be able to get in your own house are you
sure my kids need me I'm 130 miles away
from home I can't get to them I feel
helpless
no but if it's the fact that you're
doing this it's not okay you need to
pick up the phone now
[Music]
no we need this is guys no we're just
fine you're not following anything right
now
this is off limits no okay wait tell us
everything oh my God what
this is like really really really like
it's getting bad like she's on the phone
with her mother-in-law and the
mother-in-law is telling her that I was
there yeah the girls the girls are down
we have to go wait wait wait wait I'm
telling you can't stop stop stop stop
stop Lenny hoxton he's really
disappointed me
super disappointing me I don't know
what's going on in Lenny's mind I just
know that he's lost his mind
so
I think so I mean just the ship of his
head you just it was up to no good you
know some men they just have this shape
that you just can tell my mother-in-law
called me and told me that my husband
was bringing in a woman yeah I would be
like yeah right so disrespectful what is
wrong with him
ball heads cheats a lot oh wait
the ball head is like wait don't you
think
cheat come on
[Music]
[Music]